I'm sure you're aware of this. Lots of
people are talking about an Israeli
soldier sledgehammering a Jesus statue
of an Israeli tank bulldozing a St.
[music] George statue on Palm Sunday.
All these reports and videos of the
ultraorththodox [music]
Jews who who spit towards Christian
pilgrims.
>> I wish I guess [music] the Muslims are
treating the Christians in Lebanon very
very well.
>> No, no, we'll get to that. But my point
is this is out in the open and people
are talking about it and they're and
they're so what why is it happening and
what does [music] it mean? This is the
important question. What does it mean
for future Christian Jewish relations
left unresponded [music] to? It's, you
know, in fact, they say this to me.
Well, you're right about what Muslims do
to Christians. Well, [music] well,
you're a hypocrite. Why don't you point
out what Jews are doing to Christians?
So, I need I need a response, an answer.
How how does one respond to [music]
this?
>> How can I respond to the act of a single
soldier
>> is coming out and it's it's being
propagated this topic [music] of uh
Israeli anti-siment towards
Christianity.
>> Yeah. Tucker Carlson.
>> Tucker Carlson. Well, unless Islam is
reinvented
theology. Yeah.
Idor Netanyahu, thank you for joining
me.
>> Thanks. Thanks for having me. I
appreciate it.
>> You're an Israeli physician and a
playwright known for several historical
and political dramas exploring war,
ideology, and moral conflict. And and
these include, of course, uh Worlds and
Collision and A Happy End. And um and
you also happen to be um the brother of
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu. and we met here in Zagreb um
just the other day because uh for the
the translation the release in Croatian
of one of your books um a mark which uh
we'll get to as well um but again thanks
for joining me and agreeing to take a
few questions um and let's actually in
fact begin with your work your
playrights and um how any of them I'm
I'm a little familiar with worlds and
collision but how they deal with the
topics of civilizational and ideological
conflict and um especially in the
context of today
>> the plays themselves basically uh they
tell stories okay I don't I don't
believe in preaching to the audience
>> written originally in Hebrew
>> yeah all my all my work is written
originally in Hebrew and uh I I'm
translate my novels into English because
my English is not good enough but to
translate a play unless you're
Shakespeare or write the kind of things
that Shakespeare does I find fairly easy
to translate into English. And because
I'm I make certain that translations are
good in English. It's a way of
introducing the plays to
foreign directors and theaters outside
of Israel. You just give the English
version.
>> So I've been lucky that my plays have
been produced in various countries,
including New York, by the way, in off
Broadway in two separate theaters. How
do they relate? you I mean uh you you
know I don't uh I don't put politics
directly into my plays but the human
mind is such that the politics are there
inside it
>> no matter what you do of course you you
insert your ideas but can I can only
tell you that I try to
to let the other side which I might
oppose I try to have them express their
ideas as as well as the can for the
character to convince the audience and
sometimes it happens that at the end of
the play
even the actress I remember played a
certain part she told me that she so
admired this person and that was the
person that was my nemesis in the play
in terms of his ideology and what he did
so
>> but I I touch on various themes to do
with the suppression of the
ideas
major major
issue I would say in the west that's
actually my novel also marqu has a lot
to do with that this we're undergoing
here a
in today's world or the west of today a
suppression of you know what suppression
of freedom of speech that's basically
what's happening
>> and uh it can be done in many we see it
also in science
climate Okay. My my my no my play worlds
a collision are about it happened before
the issue of climate change. It happened
happens in the 50s. At that time by the
way the world I don't know if you know
everybody was
in alarm about a coming ice age.
>> That time it was the world is getting
colder. Okay.
>> Little did they know.
>> Yeah.
>> And uh so anyway that's that was
scientific suppression.
Why do you why do you think um this
[clears throat] obvious which I
completely agree with you this mass
attack on freedom of speech and the
irony is it seems to emanate mostly from
what we would call leftist or illiberal
institutions and peoples who
historically were the ones who actually
championed free speech. So what's going
on with that sort of inter
>> depends how you categorize leftism.
Certainly communism was very much
against any free speech and I consider
them left. I don't know I don't consider
any other way. I think a lot of it
indeed has to do with the fact that
Marxism and communism infiltrated
the I would say the less radical left in
the west influenced that a lot
influenced it not only the matter of
suppression of free speech and not
allowing the other side to uh to express
to express himself but also infiltrated
the ideology of what we call in America
liberalism.
userbed it and took it to its own
to its own
god I'm losing my English here okay
>> they took it on the way on the path that
it wanted it to be
>> right
>> I think that's
>> they manipulated it basically
>> in not they took it took it over in many
ways and that's what we're seeing here
because the in there was a tremendous
tremendous influence in the 60s and the
50s Even before that, um
I remember growing up when I was in
America and junior high school, I
remember how much there was influence of
the ideas of the Soviet Union, of
communism, and how how they tried to
convince us that more or less it's the
same type of societies, there's no
difference, etc., etc.
>> And then you had
a lot a lot of these radical elements in
the 60s. You think it's happening only
today? No, it happened also in the 60s.
>> I cannot look. I'm not a historian, so I
cannot tell you exactly how it evolved
historically.
Maybe if I were a historian like my
father was, I'd be able to understand
>> in a more wider scale
>> what is happening today. I can only see
what the things that are happening. I'm
not sure I can explain them.
>> Okay. So, one question I'd like to um
ask you is, and this is why it's good
meeting you as a fellow author, because
my field of expertise and what I write
about is primarily Islam and its
historical and past and present
interplay, interaction, conflict with
primarily the western world.
>> And um
>> you're one of the few expert on Islam
that actually speaks Arabic. I mean,
that's
>> Yes. Thank you. This is true. No,
>> it's unbelievable. People Oh, I'm an
expert. after 911 a lot of people have
ever read the Quran and the original Oh,
no. No. I don't.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, thank you for
noticing.
>> Which is which is why I often read your
stuff.
>> I I appreciate that. I'm honored. Thank
you. And um that's great. So, one of the
uh the things that I really write about
often and what has come out in my
studies is that [snorts] and you know
it's it was well capped off by the
political scientist Samuel Huntington.
wrote a very piffy sentence which is uh
the blood the borders of Islam are
bloody by which he meant wherever Islam
lives whatever neighbor Islam or Muslim
Islamic country has that's not a Muslim
they're at conflict with okay um that
was one of his observations my
historical studies in my books like
sorted scimitar that's exactly the case
too of course as and and as much as
Islam expands and its borders grow then
of course it has new new neighbors and
it goes to war with as [snorts] well.
We're here in Croatia and of course this
too was the front line of the war as
well.
So in the context of Israel, which is a
small country surrounded in essentially
an Islamic lake or sea, um do you think
that Islam does indeed pose an
existential threat? By which I mean
again that there will always be a
permanent state of hostility, not
necessarily war, because uh historically
um Islamic organiza organizations,
caliphates and sultenates went to war
when they could and they were strong
enough. But of course, if they were
weak, they're not going to proate.
They're not going to commit suicide,
>> right? Exactly. Okay. Um, so but the
hostility can always be there if it's if
it is in fact an existential thing. So
do you think in the case of Israel there
will always be a permanent state of
hostility which is obviously not ideal
and not desirable or do you think there
can ever be a true way to peacefully
coexist sincerely and not just until
Muslims get strong and then they you
know do
>> well unless Islam is reinvented its
ideology.
>> Yeah. I'm talking about both, you know,
especially the political ideology of
Islam unless that's reinvented. Yes. The
hostility will exist forever because
Islam is now unwilling to give up on
territories that they consider part of
the world that was conquered by Islam.
Okay? It already has been conquered.
Okay? So all of a sudden there's this
small people called the Jewish people
that went back to their homeland and
this homeland happened to have been
conquered in the seventh century by
Islam. But we uh
this is our homeland and we were able to
uh settle there and were able to survive
through uh
being able to withstand the onslaught of
five Arab countries and talk about 1948
when the state was established together
with a local Arab population that was
also fighting against us.
Tremendous odds in favor of the Arabs.
Tremendous odds. At that time were only
something like 600,000 Jews living in
the land living in the land of Israel
and America boycotted us. Okay, no arms
shipments. We had to get arms purchasing
somehow through Europe and uh thank God
because Stalin wanted to get rid of the
British. Okay, because the British was
controlling in that area. They helped
they helped the Arabs as much as they
could. They were totally against the
establishment of a Jewish state.
Although they received a mandate from
the League of Nations after World War
II, after World War I to enable the
establishment of the Jewish state, but
they quickly reneged and so and they
were helping the Arabs in any way they
could.
Stalin wanted to get rid of the wanted
to take over the Middle East, wanted to
get rid of the of the British. So he
enabled he allowed the Czech which were
then under his control to send us arms.
The Czech had a arms industry. It wasn't
a huge amount of arms, but it was
something and enabled us to withstand
the onslaught of the Arabs and survive
and establish a state. Very, you know,
very small state, impossible borders,
but it was better than nothing.
But
there has there has been never a
willingness a real willingness whether
the local Arabs what we now call the
Palestinian Arabs to accept the idea of
a Jewish state. Never. whenever any
compromise was offered them where there
in 1937
where the British set up appeal
commission and they said okay let's
create a tiny tiny Jewish state along
the coast
and we accepted it okay they refused
they refused the solution would have
been a much bigger Arab country
and then in 1947 the UN partition plan
they divided a small piece of land into
a Jewish state and an Arab Palestinian
state. They refused that too. Said, "No
way. We don't want any Jewish presence."
So on and so forth.
certain prime ministers in Israel
negotiated whether with Arafat
and then later with Abu Mazim the
current leader of the Palestinian
movement basically willing to give them
the entire bank 97%
and East Jerusalem except for the Jewish
quarter they still refused.
They refuse because they they cannot in
their ideology they cannot allow
themselves to recognize the ex the the
possibility of Jewish sovereignty in any
part of the land and that has a lot to
do with their beliefs their religion. I
don't think that's going to change any.
And so I don't foresee once again unless
there's some revolution and the thinking
of the mindset of Islam. I don't think
that will change. So there will be this
hostility as you said. But obviously if
they see they cannot do anything about
it. They're not going to commit suicide.
They'll be quiet for a while until they
feel they have a chance.
>> Which is which is interesting because it
goes back to my point and you also
mentioned Arafat.
I recall that uh during the Oslo Accords
that he came under a lot of criticism by
Arabs and Muslims for supposedly giving
up too much. And at the time he said
something that was very cryptic that
most nobody would understand unless
you're a Muslim. He basically referenced
he said this is like the pact that
prophet Muhammad made with I think Kafan
tribe which if you understand what that
means is he made a pact with them and
gave them a lot. He he conceded a lot
but because he was weaker and once he
got stronger ion of breaking it and
>> when he was strong enough
>> he kept on saying it and he was recorded
saying it in two places South Africa
>> and I think somewhere else in Europe
>> and
the Israeli media was so intent and
having the alle chords go through all
the way to the end because the media at
that time were all on the left without
exception
>> that they refused to
mention
>> really
>> what Arafat says because they were of
one mind. Don't confuse me with the
facts. This is what we decided on. We're
going to go through it. It was a
disaster disastrous accords
>> that cost us thousands of lives and
we're still paying for it. What happened
in the October 7 attack
is a direct result of that because we
allowed them to establish themselves in
the Gaza Strip. That's basically it. And
this is we're still paying for it, but
we paid for it very soon after the
courts. Immediately the terrorism
started, the suicide bombings in the
streets, you name it, we had it. And uh
and that was of course that was his
intention. He never intended to have
peace with us. the
political leaders in the west are weak
including Israeli leaders and for
someone like
who was a
he was he didn't have the tendency to
fantasize Paris who was his defense
minister
had this tendency to look at maybe not
look at things concretely he was a very
concrete man I'm still at a loss to
explain how He actually believed there
was a possibility of having peace with a
professional terrorist like Arafat who
all his life was working for the
for the destruction of the Jewish state.
I I failed to understand it.
It was a matter of weakness, I think,
more than anything else. Yeah, it sounds
like if we're agreed that Islam does
pose an existential threat for the
reasons that we described because that
part of land they see it as theirs
always. It was conquered. You probably
know in Arabic they call it futua which
means they've the land has the countries
that they've conquered or the lands that
they conquered. Fut in Arabic means the
openings because they've opened them to
the light of Islam. So you can never of
course now go back to jaha and ignorance
and infidils and etc etc. same
same word in Hebrew. PUA means open.
>> Yeah. Oh, really? Okay. Okay. So, um so
I I suppose I we can from there segue to
the Iran war, the Iran war.
>> Mhm.
>> Um you [clears throat] know, for I have
to tell you, to me, I've reached the
point now with the news that I just
don't know what's going on because
>> whatever they say what's going on is the
opposite. Exactly. You should know
what's going on.
>> Yeah. If one person says it's this,
there's going to be another person with
the same authority saying that. And so
I've reached the point where unless I go
there and see for myself, I really don't
know. But I I suppose you would know a
little better than me. So um what what
is your feel? What is your take uh first
of all on what is happening in the war?
Is it sometimes I hear oh the US and
Israel are winning the war is basically
over then other people are saying oh no
actually the US and Israel have lost and
Iran is more powerful than ever. I don't
know. Do you have thoughts?
You don't have to be a genius to know
that Iran
is far far weaker was before
>> before the start of the war which the
first
>> our first attack which was done I think
a year ago when we destroyed much of
their anti-aircraft ability and then
afterwards three week long attack in
June
where Israel
or 12 days, 12 days, not three weeks,
I'm sorry,
where our flames planes flew freely over
Iran. We attacked their basically their
nuclear sites and then America finished
it off with that one single attack of
the PDU bombers. And now for the past 40
for the 40 days massive bombings by both
Israel and by America destroying their
missile in large to a large extent their
missile ballistic missile capability
further destroying their nuclear program
and doing other damage.
There's no question they're weak.
They're not stronger. They cannot be
stronger. Okay.
>> Yeah. Which is why it's amazing how
people talk.
>> Well, yeah, people talk. Okay. Sure.
Yeah. Of course, they're stronger. So,
you don't have to be genius to
understand that. The question is, how
would how would this how would this end?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. That's that's a big question.
>> So, is it safe to say that um as the way
you described it, of course, is logical
that um because another question is what
exactly is the endgame? What is the what
is it that's desired? Um is it was it is
it regime change? Is it just destroying
the nuclear um option and all that? But
what you're describing makes sense as
well. It sounds like a a slowgrade
degradation, you know, bit by bit of the
country's capacity and power to be a
threat. Is that logical?
>> From Israel's point of view, the there
was a twoprong threat. One was the
nuclear
nuclear weapons that they were intent on
having
>> and I think that threat has been
at least
put away for a long time. Okay.
And then the problem was the massive
ballistic missile program that they were
working on. You can intercept only a
certain amount of missiles. Okay. So
let's say you intercept 90% which is a
huge percentage rate. 10% will go will
enter. If they would have had
tens of thousands of long range
ballistic missiles, let's say they rain
a thousand of them at one time in one in
one blast. A hundred of them, each one
with half a ton warhead rains down at
Tel Aviv. You don't need a nuclear
weapon that will destroy Tel Aviv.
And that's what they were working on.
And they were working of course also on
developing the nuclear weapon which of
course Iran called Israel a one bomb
country.
So we had no choice. Even if America
would not have gone in with us, it
wouldn't have mattered. We would have
attacked Iran in order to stop that. If
you want to if you want to survive,
that's what you have to do. And Iran was
saying openly that they're going to
destroy the Jewish state. They claim
they're not going to developing nuclear
weapons. Okay, the lie. But that they
were intent on destroying the
>> Tell us about that. about what Iran says
it's propaganda. What
>> there was a main square in Thran
>> where they had a clock. The clock was
countdown to the destruction of the
Jewish state.
>> One of the first things we did in the
June bombing was we sent a bomb and
destroyed that clock. Okay. [laughter]
>> How can they have that and then claim
that they're not um antagonistic?
>> No, they always say that Israel must be
destroyed. They don't say they're not
antagonistic. They just claim that
they're not going to they're against
there's a fatwa against nuclear weapons.
Well, we all know that they lied.
They've been lying for years.
>> But that's part also of the you're
allowed to do that in order to achieve
the goals of Islam.
>> Especially the Shia
>> and to especially because they're the
weaker ones and they have to
>> they've internalized the concept of tea
which allows deception.
>> Right. Right. Exactly.
>> Deception for the cause of Islam, not
deception. They're not going to cheat
you on selling a house or something. I'm
not talking about you're allowed to
deceive for the cause of Islam
>> power is law against the infido.
>> Look they they are radical
to my mind they're crazy the leaders
and they are willing to they knew that
had they launched an attack on Israel a
nuclear attack on Israel we would
retaliate
and to them okay so 10 million Iranians
will die for the cause of Allah. So
what? It's a that's a
a small price to pay for the destruction
of this country that seized the holy
land, holy Muslim land. Okay,
>> that's this is why also I've been I've
been pointing this out and you know in
my field my expertise is you know less
political but more theological and I've
been looking at the esquetology the end
days of Shiaism
especially in the context of the
doctrine of the Mahi. Okay, so you
probably know this with the Shia uh they
they believe in the the concept of the
Mahi who's this end figure who comes to
usher in the end times and of course
empower Islam and um they also are as
you know they have the whole martyrdom
kind of almost complex and this is why
we many people don't are not aware of
this in the west probably but they
engage in asho where they whip and
flagagillate themselves.
>> Yeah. So to them martyrdom is a very
welcomed thing that they look forward
to. And so if you take that component
martyrdom which they embrace and you
take the idea that they also very
strongly especially the IRC um very much
strongly
um embrace the concept of the mei and
helping usher him in which includes
defeating the enemies of Islam which
would be of course Israel primarily in
in the in the region. So fused together,
it it seems to me that's a very um
potent and dangerous tonic to have a
nuclear weapon.
>> And don't forget that they're developing
nuclear they develop ballistic missiles
beyond [snorts] the range of Israel.
Okay, as of now they already have
ballistic missiles that can reach all
the way to Paris. Okay, and very shortly
I think to London. and they were working
a ballistic intercontinental ballistic
missiles that will be able to reach the
east coast of the United States. Their
mission is not Israel. Their mission and
they talk about it
is the mission to
impose Islam on the entire world.
>> They say this publicly. There's records
of this.
>> There's first of all, well, this is part
of their ideology. Yeah. This is part of
their ideology. They don't have to
>> Okay.
>> I can't quote you exactly. It's not as
explicit as the countdown to the
destruction of Israel.
>> Well, yeah, but yeah. But yeah, it is
part of the I don't know of a clock that
says countdown to the destruction of
America, but that's that's the great
enemy. They call it the great Satan.
>> It's implicit. That's for sure.
>> And uh certainly I know that you know
the if you go to the Sunni side, the
Muslim Brotherhood, they talked about it
openly. The leader of Kamas, Sheh Yasin,
absolutely talked about imposing Islam
on the world, on the entire world. This
is the this is their war. This was the
leader of Hamas until he became leader
no more. Okay, through certain means.
But no, look, the ideal solution of
course in Iran will be regime change.
Real regime change. That is these people
will be put in jail,
pay the price of the horrible things
they did to the Iranian people.
>> That means dissolving the IRGC
essentially.
>> The question is how do you achieve it?
You you cannot achieve it by b dropping
bombs. Okay? But nobody wants to go into
Iran and I mean it can it could have
been achieved that the American army
gone into Iran and fought the war. But
America's unwilling to do that and maybe
for good reason. The question is whether
there will be enough forces in Iran that
we'd be willing to take on the regime.
For that you need weapons. Okay.
Could it be that there are that there
will be inside the Iranian army and
inside the revolutionary guards? Will
there be officers that will say enough
is enough? Will be the will there be
those who say I have to revenge the
killing of my son who was a protester?
You know the tens of thousands that they
slaughtered in the streets, the
protesters.
Will that happen in Iran? I don't think
anybody can predict. I don't think
anybody knows. But if that will happen,
eventually there will be regime change.
Now, that can be furthered by causing
further economic damage to Iran if they
don't have the money to pay the IRGC
soldiers or the regular army or the
besiege. They won't have these
organizations will crumble. Okay? And so
I think it's
I I I I hope that it will be the war
will continue. It seems like they're not
going to give up in negotiations. The
war will continue so that their ability
to
continue to exist as a viable entity,
which means they have the kind of
economy that allows them to continue to
exist. I hope that will be taken care of
in the next stage of the war if the war
resumes.
I think that will be the best solution
for the Iranian people and for the world
at large.
If there will be an agreement that will
lift some sanctions and allow them to
continue to rule Iran.
That's not a good solution.
But it doesn't mean that we have not
achieved a tremendous victory in what
we've done both Israel and America
because of the weakening the tremendous
weakening of their abilities to cause
harm and damage.
>> Yeah. No, that is demonstrable that
they're being weakened.
So, speaking of war, one of the themes
that uh I've I'm always interested in,
of course, I write about jihad, which is
a doctrine, a coherent body of uh
teachings in Islam on how to prosecute
warfare. I've also written a lot about
the, you know, the justosition of that
against let's say just war theory as it
came grew in the west. And I'm wondering
is um does Jud Judaism have anything
similar to this? A particular notion of
war that's rooted in Judaism or is it
just pragmatism?
No,
>> we're not going to discuss Jewish
[laughter]
Jewish the Jewish religion. No, but the
Jewish the
Judaism is a both a religion and in many
sense a nationality that it's the
religion of the Jewish people. Okay. And
uh
of course we there is a
the time of the Bible in ancient times
you know when the the Jews by legend or
as according to the old testament we
came from Egypt and we conquered the
land of their forefathers
various tribes who lived there in the
land of Canaan.
And then like all ancient peoples in the
ancient times and and you know
throughout history you have other
peoples that want to conquer this
portion of the land that portion of the
land. So you had King David who was able
to establish
the kingdom
was able to defeat the Philistines
who were a cre
people
>> who inhabited the coastal part of the
land of Israel. the Romans after the you
know the Jews would revolt against the
Romans time and again okay they refused
the only people in the Roman Empire
people would resist the Romans okay but
once they were conquered by the Romans
they basically stopped revoling okay the
only ones who kept on revoling were the
Jews okay because they wanted
independence
>> and at a certain point in time the
Romans said enough is enough can't stand
it anymore and they wanted to erase the
country and erase It's a country that
was then called Judea. And they wanted
to erase the name of Judea. And so they
decided to call the land Palestine,
named after the Philistines of ancient
times. And that's how the name Palestine
came to be known. Has nothing to do. The
Arabs were not in existence there in the
land at that time.
So, but yeah, look, wars happened all
the time and you have to fight for your
survival and we wanted to fight for
independence. And the last great revolt
happened
in 19 in the year 132.
>> We call the great revolt the revolt the
bigger revolt against the Romans where
the temple was destroyed. That was the
year 70 AD.
But 60 some years later there was
another even bigger revolt. Barcoa.
>> That's right. Baroo revolt. Yeah. That
lasted. We're able to establish our own
rule for three years until finally Rowan
Empire brought in huge massive amounts
of forces and were able to crush it as
well.
>> Um so in the context
>> but no we don't have any
ideology of wanting to
>> establish Judaism throughout the world.
It doesn't exist.
>> No no I didn't mean that itself. I meant
as a as a way of um for example just war
theory in the in the Catholic tradition
you know says you you can do this you
can't do this you should only fight when
it's in self-defense for example whereas
jihad of course is primarily offensive
warfare so I was wondering in that
context is is there some tradition in
the Judaism that is has its own version
or is more like this or more like that
>> I don't know of any rules of warfare in
terms of Judaism but not I'm not an
expert on Jewish theology Right.
>> I think the
wars of self-defense are are the correct
way of looking at the warfare. But of
course, sometimes you have to preempt.
If you're being threatened, you have no
choice. And Israel is a small country.
And so
>> there was some debate actually.
>> So we did not preempt let's say in 73.
>> America told us not to preempt. Big
mistake.
>> And the preeemption argument I think is
a little stronger nowadays. For example,
uh maybe you're familiar, um Donald
Trump was attacking the pope and they
had a little spat because I the pope was
was condemning the war in very vocal
terms. And [clears throat] then later uh
Catholic um I think pre-lates and
archbishops said flat out this is not a
just war.
>> And then but others said it was. And um
one of the the criteria of just war is
that it has to be defensive and that
preemptive to say I'm preempting that's
the problem. It doesn't necessarily fit
the defensive model which assumes you
have to wait until you're attacked. But
I think the difference that not many
people are taking into consideration is
that the nuclear question really changes
it because it's one thing in the old
days when you're dealing with
conventional warfare or especially you
know preodern coming in with swords and
spears it's one thing to say I'll wait
until you attack me because the damage
you can do is going to be pretty minimal
but if you wait in the context of a
nuclear weapon and say well I'm not
going to preempt and let a nuclear
weapon happen. If you wait well that
could mean complete obliteration. Um, so
I do think that that adds a little more
>> in the in the case of Israel, not only
nuclear weapons. I mean, it's the
ballistic missile. No, the country is so
it's not only that you have sometimes
you have no choice. And there if you're
certain that they're going to attack,
okay,
from the public opinion standpoint of
the world, then and that's what that's
why America pressured us in 1973
when we knew we're going to be attacked
in a few hours and we wanted to preempt
and use our air force to attack the
armies that were amassing against us.
Kissinger who was then secretary of
state called our prime minister God and
basically demanded that we don't preempt
okay because it looked bad. Okay. But uh
so she did what he asked her to do.
Maybe she felt she had no choice but it
cost us
tremendously tremendously both in terms
of lives we lost and beyond that also.
Erh in 1967 we preempted because the
Arab armies were amassing once against
us.
Egypt
kicked out the UN forces in the Sina
desert and brought his army into the
Sina desert declared that Israel will be
destroyed and the in the radio, Arabic
radio in Hebrew, they were talking about
raping our women and throwing us into
the sea, blah blah blah blah blah blah.
And uh
we had no choice but to preempt at that
time. And thank God we did. And it was a
very successful war.
We fought both Egypt and then Syria and
then Jordan. And not Lebanon. Lebanon
was quiet. Okay. They didn't attack us.
They didn't at that time they didn't
threaten us. It was also governed more
or less by Christians. So there was
actually fairly good relations with
Lebanon.
A war of prehension is not a bad thing
to do if
if you're just to attack without the
threat of being attacked of course is
aggression.
>> But there's a difference between a war
of aggression, a war of preeemption.
Preemption is just another way of
defense. That's all.
>> Especially as we pointed out when the
other side is going out of its way to
say you said they have this clock
ticking about the existence of Israel. I
mean that's very provocative obviously.
No, in this case of this case of Israel,
we know that they were going back into
developing nuclear weapons in a very
rapid rate. We had intelligence about
that and going doing starting to do it
very deep in the mountains where our
bombs could not penetrate
>> as well as as well as having a huge
ballistic missile program much much
bigger than they had before. So, we had
to destroy it. We had we couldn't
continue that way. You're not going to
wait until your head is being cut off.
That's crazy.
>> Yeah. But despite all that, Israel's,
you know, it's interesting because
Israel's greatest um non-Jewish
supporters, of course, would be
evangelical American Christians.
>> Mhm.
>> And as of as of late, I'm sure you're
aware of this because it seems to be
it's it's all over the place. Lots of
people are talking about it. They're
showing images and photos and bringing
witnesses talking about things like the
the main one, of course, is an Israeli
soldier sledgehammering a Jesus statue.
Speaking of Lebanon, it was in Lebanon.
Um, another video is an Israeli tank
bulldozing a St. George statue on Palm
Sunday, I think, also in Lebanon 2025.
And then there's, of course, you're
familiar with this, all these reports
and videos of I think it's the
ultraorththodox Jews who would who spit
towards Christian pilgrims, nuns,
clergy, um, in the old city of
Jerusalem.
>> Yeah. I wish I guess and the Muslims are
treating the Christians in Lebanon very,
very well.
>> No, no, no, no. or or treating
>> we'll get to that or are they treating
the cops in the Egypts very well.
>> No, no, we'll get to that. But my point
is um
>> this is out in the open and people are
talking about it in their and they're so
what why is it happening and what does
it mean? This is the important question.
What does it mean for future Christian
Jewish relations because left left
unresponded to it's you know it people
are going to say oh in fact they say
this to me they say oh you're right
about what Muslims do to Christians.
Well, well, you're a hypocrite. Why
don't you point out what what Jews are
doing to Christians? So, I need I need a
response, an answer. How how does one
respond to this?
>> How can I respond to the act of a single
soldier who's a who's an idiot maybe
full of hate and he he uses a
sledgehammer? I mean, you you take him,
you
>> So, you don't it's not a pattern. You
don't think it's necessarily a deep
>> I don't know of any such pattern. I know
that the army is
will punish him has severely reprimanded
him and whatever the judges decide how
he'll be punished he'll be punished if a
tank went over look you think you think
the driver tank knows exactly what he's
going over if he's going over a statue
you think he did it on purpose maybe he
did if he did it on purpose then he also
has to be punished I don't know of any
you you cannot control what certain
people do the ultra orthodox
what what they do,
how they behave is one thing, but I'm
sure it's a small minority among them.
But the only place where the Christians
in the Middle East are thriving as
Israel. We protect them.
In our in the village where I live, we
have two Christian families that
basically fled from Nazareth. They
couldn't tolerate what the Muslims were
doing there. They're taking over
Nazareth.
uh he was the extortion of his the shops
of his family and all that basically
said I can't live there anymore I can't
raise my children there Bethlehem used
to be a Christian city
when we foolishly but the Oslo Accords
allowed Arafat in to Bethlehem
did what Muslims do and it's no longer a
Christian city I think it has now maybe
10% Christians as far as I know they
they can't live with once the Muslims
rule they can't it's becomes
intolerable. Okay. As a matter of fact
after the six day war when we annexed
East Jerusalem
the leaders of Bethlehem came to us and
asked to be annexed as well. Okay. And
we foolishly
told them that no we can't do that. They
thought there would be tremendous world
pressure against it. Public opinion.
We uh look the relations I would say in
general between Christians who live in
Israel and Jews are very good. Okay.
There are many young Christians they
don't have to but they volunteer to
serve in the Israeli army
and that's the kind of relationship we
have and
with some individuals who misbehave.
How can anybody control that? I mean,
it's like uh
saying, "Oh, there are so many
Christians in the, you know, in the
whatever Los Angeles that
try to cheat and steal and
yeah, individuals. So, they go to jail.
what
>> the question is whether the government
does something that's against and that's
not
>> I will I will concede to your point that
you were raising earlier which is you
know well how are Christians treated in
the Islamic world and of course that is
one of the that's one of my primary
fields that I I focus on and I know a
lot about I've written one book about it
crucified again um and yeah it's true
you know at least um you know in
countries like in Egypt all around the
Islamic world Egypt Nigeria Pakistan um
you know churches are bombed and blown
up Christians are attacked and killed
and massacred. Women are habitually um
kidnapped, raped, forced, and converted
into Islam. And the police look the
other way.
>> That's it. The authorities look the
other way. That's a difference.
>> Yes, that's true, too. In
>> Israel, we do not allow the Muslims as
far as we can in order to harass
Christians. There's tremendous amount of
crime in the Arab cities, and that
includes also Nazareth, and that's where
they're fleeing away from.
>> You you cannot you cannot control social
behavior, okay? But you can control
illegal behavior and certainly that's
what Israel is doing in terms of
protecting the Christians.
Israel cannot be faulted
for acting anything against the
Christians. On the contrary, it's
exactly the opposite. And certainly
Lebanon,
the Christians are want us to succeed in
driving outbalah.
They they don't want us to stop. the
when we started fighting exchanging
withaha they urged us on they urge us on
to continue because they're suffering
frombalah as much as we are from the
Shiite forces that are that Iran backs
we've always had very good relations
with the Christians in Lebanon okay we
still do
they want to achieve peace with us but
it's not so simple because other
elements within Lebanon of course are
against it.
>> What What do you say to people uh and
everyone of course is familiar with him
and this is why much of this is is
coming out and it's it's being
propagated this topic of uh Israeli
anti- sentiment towards Christianity.
>> Yeah. Tucker Carlson.
>> Tucker Carlson. And um what I find
interesting about him though is you know
he he he shows these images and talks
about it but he'll never he'll never say
a thing about Christians under the
Islamic world. And he actually praises
you know how Islam is wonderful. He
recently said Muslims love Jesus. uh you
know so it's very uh interesting how you
know on the one hand I think it's fair
for him to talk about what's happening
in Israel and to for us to you know give
a response but I do find it odd that the
much greater attack on Christians which
is by Muslims there's a world there's a
report that comes out annually it's
called the world watch list and uh it
comes from a well-known human rights
organization called open doors and it
ranks the 50 worst nations where
Christians are being persecuted
>> habitually about 39 are Muslim and the
top uh 12, which is extreme persecution,
which means if you're just seen or known
to be a Christian, you could actually
just get killed or worse. Okay, as in
raped and then killed, um nine out of
those uh 11 or 12 are Muslim. So, it's
just interesting that the much greater
um assault on Christianity is kind of
getting a pass.
>> There is no assault on Christians by
Jews in Israel. Individual happens to do
something. Yes. Okay. That happens. It
happens everywhere. Okay. Can happen
anywhere in any city in the world. But
there's no assault on Christians by
Israel. On the contrary, we consider the
Christians our allies just the other way
around. Okay? And the Christians
consider us as protectors. That's the
objective truth. And it can be distorted
in any way you want to, but it's
distortion and it's lies. Okay. So, a
great part of the world as we know is
against Israel with many of course
accusing your brother Benjamin Netanyahu
of war crimes and being a war criminal.
I I believe if he goes to certain
countries he would be arrested. So how
do you respond to that? And more
importantly what message do you have for
the world?
>> The world is in bad shape
if the world we're talking about the
west. I'm not talking about the other
world. Okay. No, actually in the east I
mean countries like India have
the prime minister of India has I would
say praised Israel for what it was doing
after October 7 for fighting against
these crazy radicals these terrorists
as well as other countries as well the
illnesses of the west that is the great
illness it's an illness that is
>> tell me about this illness
>> it's the illness that is the product of
lack of will lack of will to survive.
>> I mean, look at the Muslim migration
into Europe. You know, how does that fit
into all this?
>> It fits everything. The Muslim migration
is a result, first of all, of the fact
that
the spirit is gone. The spirit is gone.
So, they don't make children. Okay?
Israel has the highest rate of birth
rate in the in the Western world. The
Jewish birth rate is higher than that of
the Arabs. Can you believe that? Okay.
because we believe in ourselves and we
want to survive and we want to thrive.
So the Muslim migration is obviously a
product of that because they need
people, they need workers. We don't
produce enough people. Okay? So they get
it from the closest place which is the
the Muslim world. But no, this is
reflective of a lack of will. There is a
lack of belief in the West. This is a
product of World War I, maybe even more
than World War II.
uh this this spiritedness.
It's a certainly in many ways a lack a
product of the uh decline of religion
but in general decline in the belief
this has been hammered to the young
people of the west by their professors
>> that the west is wrong, the west is
is evil.
you know, not considering everything in
the last 400 years that the West has
brought to the world, which is freedom,
okay?
All that goes by the wayside.
And with that uh
you can say that a people in Israel that
is being threatened with annihilation
with these kamas terrorists coming in
600 to 6,000 [snorts] of them
filming gleefully their great acts of
killing babies and chopping their heads
and burning them and raping our women
all on tape and burning the houses of
families. is horrible. The things you
would think of would happen in the
Middle Ages, okay? But they're doing it
openly.
And then the West, the the
demonstrators, the young people, even
before we did anything, before we went
to Gaza, chanting against Israel and
pro- Hamas,
you know, the Nazis used to hide their
atrocities. At least
they didn't. I mean, they documented it
because they're crazy Germans. They
wanted everything documented, but they
didn't say, "We're going we're now
destroying or annihilating 6 million
Jews and a million gypsies." They hide
it. They hid it because they knew that I
would say the moral sense of people
would be against it. They hid it also
for their own people. Now, you can say,
of course, they knew about it people,
but it wasn't anything open. It was
open.
They were proud of it.
>> They were proud of what they were doing.
And there's a long history of that go
cameras or whatever it's called. And
they were filming themselves all the
time in order to
because they knew it will be accepted
very well by the the Gazin civilians.
This is a great thing. And of course,
many civilians joined in once once the
uh the border was opened.
the civilians rushed both to steal but
also to rape and to murder.
Now that's one thing about Arab society
or Muslim society or radical Muslim or
Hamas or whatever and the hatred towards
the Jews and the hatred towards Israel.
Okay, the hatred which was imbued by
them since they were babies.
The horrible thing is that in the west
they are the ones who are being lauded
and of course with the lies. Oh, no.
They never raped anybody. No. [laughter]
Okay. They take they take, of course,
they also raped, of course, the and also
murdered. Some of the hostages, the
women hostages, they when the family
was, you know, the the red-haired mother
and their two babies that we found, the
bullets, the bodies were received by us,
they're executed with bullets in their
heads.
These are the people that are being
lauded
in the West. this tremendous tremendous
illness of the west. Tremendous illness
of the west. I cannot explain it
otherwise. And uh to explain it only
through anti-semitism I think is too
easy. Yeah, sure the world hates the
Jews always has probably always will.
It's something that's very old.
But
this is goes beyond that. Goes well
beyond that. There's a grave illness
that has attacked the west. Once again,
I'm not a historian, so I cannot tell
you exactly all the sources and but I'm
sure somebody who has an analytical mind
time will come when all this craziness
will be elucidated. How this h how could
this could happen?
>> Okay, let's end it on a happier note.
Um, we met as I mentioned earlier.
>> The happy note is that we're doing
something against it and I hope you'll
succeed. The happy note is America Trump
is trying to reverse
>> this downward slide, horrible downward
slide. And I hope that he will succeed.
Let's see. Let's see. Certainly in
Israel, we're not going to give up. No
matter what happens to the West, we're
we will continue.
>> But go ahead. You wanted to ask?
>> Well, I I was going to end it and uh by
actually talking going back to the
beginning because as I was mentioning,
we're here we're we're here. here in
Croatia um because of the translation of
your book it marqu which is over there.
So um yeah that's that's the happy note.
Why don't you tell us a little bit about
that book and of course in any way that
you can apply it to the grand themes
that we've addressed.
>> Yeah well it's happy because it's a
humoristic book. It's a site or parody
whatever you want to call it and it's a
parody that I wrote many years ago
nearly 30 years ago about the left in
Israel. Okay. and about I would say so
not only political but social I would
say social political parody and satire
and
it's also about cancel culture I'm
talking about many years ago okay this
is in Israel this is not new okay the
way the left tries to impose
its ideas and have total control of the
platforms of expression I would say
whether it's theater whether it's film
whether it's academia
whether it's media and so I was through
this satire I was trying to talk about
these topics
I mean there's a plot there's everything
and anyway it's all of a sudden it's
raised interest in certain countries in
Europe because they see hey this is
happening to us you know so it was
translated into into Italian into
Russian into Serbian now into Croatian
and
a few months into into Czech
So I'm here in Croatia for the
creation edition of the book and
hopefully it'll be translates translated
finally into English.
>> It's been translated into the first
>> then I'll read it. Okay.
>> The first transl unless you know it was
first translated into Russian many years
ago. The Russians felt an affinity to it
because hey, this is, you know,
something that something that happened
to us in Soviet Russian times when the
government imposed on us and they saw a
certain a certain I would say affinity
to what they said sounded sounded
familiar, but it will soon be translated
into English and hopefully I'll send you
a copy when I appreciate that. That'd be
great.
>> Okay, you do. Thank you very much for
taking the time to speak with me and I
wish you great success with your books
and your future endeavors.
>> Great. I wish you great success with
your important endeavors.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Thank you very much. Appreciate it.
>> Bring back the fight.
Bring back the [music] flame.
Bring back the fire and [music] the
rightous name.